what does this have
here the cover of my next album and
viruses
themselves on the ipad
so that such a mind and wants to be clear about
one and these are my essentials
[Music]
my first essential in the bible
is essential because really well for in order
to learn  of the Lord's pay
because the greatest and best that has
happened and learned has helped me to
control many emotions it has helped to
control and have patience so one
of the most important of the essentials
of areas like I have the bible
I also need the  Rosary This is a gift
that this inhabitant friend of mine gave me,
especially I always carry it with me
because the blessing she is strong,
very, very, very, very, every time you see me I
know that faithfully the believer of
her started gave herself a long time ago
and always  has preserved
yes always before singing before
traveling before 2000
I am completely used to it is a plan
and a perfection for which you have
to thank
him the following l  I have always
said that men have to have their
watches and they must also know the time so
that they feel good and I say that to feel
as I say to you how not empty hands
the collections of errors in you
battlefield richard mille and I always walk
with a  clock of the strong hour and that such a
day always one never knows
I have an opposite robot change
I always go with a watch put on
example this is a patek philippe that I
bought it a long time ago what makes the
collection or with its box and I have something
of collection and 5 in the world and
diamonds are factories and that for
me to like them later they have to be the
factor only of 5 in the world I like the
gift of collection it gives you a
de facto security of wherever
the next one arrives from  perfumes, something essential in
one that one must always see well,
women from all over the world will buy them
because I think that a good
perfume must work, they have to be 100% perfumes,
such as ahuatepec, hugo, they have
to be oil that and science that of
perfumes in one and when I like it I always like to
have something different each trip because I
change the perfume with a project I have
different ones so I have another cheap one
but I have this one I have others for this one
this week we are going to have the
the same but that of another another of another
fragrance active and rotating essential colors
the cold playstation 6 but wherever
I go I always want to look for
what is coming out new for the favorite
this must be that I can with my
work team think of  that of the
loss from time to time but from time to
time he loses and that's how it was because we
feel good playing we share a lot
we do tournaments with this one I ask for the
revenge of the other two to zero and
as already well something that we get used to
which we always have  a lump
playstation yesterday playstation don't let him
stay wherever he goes
we always have the playstation
the table like the tower table the zombie
the female and I like it a lot  or people that
the new players, those of us who were,
what happens, we like it, we are going to be
aware of 5, it is part of the neo, a
prevention action plan, watching the
videos of once I entered the show,
looking at a ball, and it is because I like
sports a lot  and I like to practice it
and something that can always something with me
something while I feed
the ipad something that I use to write
to save ideas it will develop the
idea for the mention this idea occurred
I want to wait it will write it down on the ipad
for songs and studies  like
writing with a like I'm going to
write with a pen and paper
let's go to the ipad I also have
all the songs I've recorded on the new ones it's
like a like a computer more more more
more portable besides maybe the
applications the games  many things that it
has not only in me but in the
whole world it is true that an ipad is very
important to catch dívar in all of
football I have my ipad let me get out of
loving you the info  rmation the next thing is a
bundle and especially is that I tell you the
electrical bundle of this iphone of
android
and auxiliary computers I saw the hard disk and something
that always has to go very well that I
always ask about that and if I would
know what  the day does not work because
when one arrives at the room from one
the tour we go that he takes out his computer
from the phone a piece of paper to continue to
continue and when you do not have that one guy
as special as this one well there is a problem
the next one is a juris a bedroom coat
for  the cold, well, we always keep
rotating all year long on the tour as if
we were working and we almost always get a
cold place and I'm in the air on the plane
I always have to have an audience that
with me always a lawyer accustomed
to that although I'll go to the car  that it's
hot a lot of people ask me does carlos make me
a little more like a bourgeois
that I'm already getting used to being covered and
warm besides the south and sometimes
you want to get off in some places or
other but what one cannot live like
the guri meta because he has lived sometimes goes
by unnoticed something that always
meets
this cold English of the new firmware collection well
if they can install clothes and that well
I like to go because they are gray well just as
cold  I don't make a good good clothes to
clarify for one to cover the
butter guide because the brand but let's treat
gods like a good one a good one because it
is also to buy
[Music]
but if it moves we are going to form the
curls in the new thing of having used  before it
had controls but now you can use
this to keep it up to date like
we say to each other no about that something that 'no
with the lump and removing the one you
gave me put it where it is there and now
we understand some of two of the
essential things that I  I am in the cult of
all men who are seeing me in
phases and as we say we love the
scented one the dog of the king of kandal
cut it so how do they do the day of the
metal that he sends indicating that he was a
wife  the barrels
and among all one these were more
essential have enjoyed we are
active and viruses
[Music]